here is Charlemagne the God's take on
President Biden I want Biden stepping in
to beat Trump the way I want him
stepping in to defend me at a bar
fight I appreciate you Karen but I don't
like our
chances the point is we don't need Biden
to beat Donald Trump just like we didn't
need RBG to stay on the court okay maybe
if RBG had retired during the Obama
years we'd still have Ro v Wade maybe
but people said no she needs to be here
to protect Ro and now look both put him
a
gun it's true they're both
gone see the facts are Biden's not
getting any younger he's not going to
get any more popular and he's not
getting a new running mate so please Mr
President give America The Ultimate
Christmas gift and step
aside this is not the funniest monologue
I've ever seen But compared to years of
Trevor Noah this guy is Norm McDonald
Bob Hope and Rodney Dangerfield all
rolled up into one and his point is much
better